i'm told the 17-game season is coming
next year it's never in question it's
never a doubt it's a done deal but peter
there's this notion that the league may
not adopt it it makes no sense to me on
the surface
uh do you make any sense of why the
league is being coy about something that
we were led to believe is a done deal
mike i think you have raised the the
most interesting scenario in all of this
which is in essence you know
especially because the salary cap
potentially could go down and could go
down significantly in 2021
make the players want to have the 17th
game
if only because
it's going to immediately inject life
and more money into the salary cap that
wasn't there because there will be
you know essentially 1 17th more
television revenue theoretically in 2021
and beyond
if you add the 17th game that's why i
think i keep reading i said they could
vote
to have the 17th game in any of the next
three years
why in the world would they not want it
they all want more money especially
because the cap could be deflated the
the cap could bottom out in 2021 that's
why i think that regardless
even whatever the vote is today mike
regardless of that i still think you're
gonna see 17 games in 2021.
i would be shocked i it just it's this
conversation has been percolating out
there for the last two or three years
mike i mean we've talked about it a
number of a number of times and
it just seems like the league is going
that way there's no doubt there's too
much money to be made and i i think that
you know as hard as stance as we saw
some of the players last year right mike
remember like my dad made that comment
about i think the players would go for
it and they were all like oh that's
crazy what the hell is phil talking
about
we've already seen that they've kind of
turned the corner and i think are open
to that idea a little bit here so i i i
would think that's coming if it doesn't
come next year it's the year after but
it's coming very soon
the reporting that is connected to the
league's supposed hesitation is along
the lines of well the pandemic has
thrown everything off well why that's
all the more reason to want to rebuild
the coffers and they pulled off a
17-week season amid the pandemic by next
year the belief is the pandemic will be
over why would you not want to add the
extra week but as it relates to this
notion that the players adopted it
reluctantly in march during the pandemic
if there's a way to dangle it as an
uncertainty and make them want it they
want to eat their vegetables right the
vegetables taste better when they want
to eat them i think there's a
psychological component and i think it's
also tied up in this annual negotiation
of what the salary cap is going to be
but to the extent that they can sell
this as a good thing to the players and
and lay the foundation that there won't
be constant complaining
week after week game after game next
year why do we have to play 17 games
that's the value in being coy about it
now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports